Tommy Lee's son Brandon shares video of
his dad unconscious there's still a lot
of bad blood between Tommy Lee and his
22 year old son with ex Pamela Anderson
on Sunday Brandon shared a graphic video
to Instagram of the 55 year old motley
crew drummer sprawled out on his floor
in his underwear
seemingly knocked out Brandon captioning
the video in part you got to show up to
be a dad big guy if you think we're so
bad then you should have showed up to a
few more B days and baseball games
someone like you couldn't raise a man
like me just move on dude we all have or
I'll put you right back to sleep which
was seemingly in response to Tommy's
father's day post honoring his own dad
and addressing his struggles and
strained relationship with his kids
quote my father taught me to respect
everyone and everything and to take care
of those that I loved when I had a child
my first child I wanted to instill those
same virtues into him sometimes I feel
like I failed as a father while it's
unclear when the video was taken the
post is troubling given the details of
the alleged assault
Tommy claimed occurred between them in
March eats he sat down with Brandon's
mom Pam earlier this month where she
opened up about the family drama
they're both adults here maybe Brandon
more so sorry but anyway you know it's
between them I wish the best of
everybody but you know we rock we're all
growing and learning and there's this is
a part of it you know I could it's it's
too bad but it's it's um like I said
it's it's the past
you